to Australia now Scott Morrison's
conservative coalition has won
re-election despite having trailed in
the polls before the country's general
election Morrison originally won power
less than a year ago becoming the third
conservative Prime Minister since 2013
he ran a campaign centred on his
personality and on the risks posed to
the middle class by the opposition
Labour Party's tax policies but still
unclear if Morrison will win the
majority government have to rely on
support of conservative independence a
short time ago Morrison's challenger
opposition Labour leader Bill Shorten
conceded defeat I want to say beyond
this room to Australian to supported
labour I know that you're all hurting
and I am too and so in the national
interest a short while ago I called
Scott Morrison to congratulate him DW
reporter Jerry Reed has been following
the Australian election very closely and
joins me now in the studio for more
Jared this is clearly a major upset
that's right for such a long time now it
had been predicted by opinion polls in
fact the exit polls today after the
election that Bill Shorten would be the
new prime minister but it just wasn't to
be this is such a an upset a shock win
for the incumbent Scott Morrison he's
really pulled his party back from the
brink this was just completely
unexpected and we're seeing some
interesting parallels people are
comparing this to the upset win of
Donald Trump in 2016 and they're calling
Bill Shorten the Australian election
Hillary Clinton so this is just yeah I
it's hard to overstate how much of an
upset this is so what exactly went wrong
for the Labour Party look they put
forward a very ambitious policy agenda
on climate action and increased taxes on
the wealthy
and comparatively the the government
their policy agenda was was not as
extensive as Labour's and perhaps labor
overwhelmed voters with what it was
trying to achieve voters consistently
put climate change as the number one
issue affecting them and when you put
the two parties side-by-side in fact
labor had more to offer in that respect
they were much more ambitious they
wanted a bigger trend towards renewables
and things like electric cars for
example where is the the government was
quite happy to just honor its commitment
to the Paris Accord but not go further
than that because of it was worried
about the economic impacts so yeah
clearly Labour's agenda didn't connect
to voters also to I think personality
played some part to build shorten is
someone that voters don't necessarily
like he is he was involved in the
downfall of two prime ministers and I
think people were suspicious of him and
perhaps like Scott Morrison a bit more
in about ten seconds can you tell us
what this means for voters it depends on
how the cards fall in the shape of the
government whether Scott Morrison can
form a majority or a minority government
will determine how far he can push his a
new agenda
Jared Reid thanks so much for joining us
a tonne of change of pace here the
Bugatti Veyron was all